nous passons ensuite à l'article 16 avec
cinq amendements identiques de
suppression et nous commençons par le
premier celui de la commission vous avez
la parole madame la rapporteur oui
monsieur le Président merci alors euh ce
présent article approuve l'annexe A je
ne sais pas si vous étiez en discussion
générale mais j'ai eu l'occasion de dire
à cette occasion que voilà je n'étais
pas euh euh tout à fait en phase avec ce
que proposait le gouvernement sur cette
annexe a euh ça comprend notamment la la
programmation cadrienale des régimes
obligatoires de base de sécurité sociale
et j'ai eu l'occasion de dire que pour
moi c'était un véritable renoncement en
fait à à à comment à réduire la dette
puisqu'on voit en fait les déficits se
creuser d'année en année en effet alors
qu'après la crise des dettes souveraines
le déficit des robes avait été réduit de
manière continue de 2011 à 2019 longame
ayant alors toujours été respecté le
présent projet de loi de financement ne
prévoit même pas de stabiliser le
déficit qui passerait de 8,8 milliards
d'euros à enfin pour 2023 à 17,5
milliards d'euros j'ai eu l'occasion de
déjà de vous le dire en 2027 par
ailleurs cette programmation peu
ambitieuse et paradoxalement optimiste
en effet elle repose sur des hypothèses
de croissance supérieure à celle du
consensus des conjoncturistes et suppose
une croissance de longâ d'environ 3 %
par an alors que l'ondame n'a plus été
respecté depuis 2020 avec 2023 une
croissance de longâ de 4,8 % hors
dépenses de crise et un dépassement
estimé à 3,5 milliards d'euros par
rapport à la dernière loi de finan de
sécurité
sociale alors j'ai bien conscience que
terminer là-dessus avec monsieur le
ministre chargé du budget ce n'est pas
faire vraiment une bonne fin de soirée
n'est-ce pas mais vous étiez prévenus
donc déjà vous nvez pas dire que vous
êtes surpris en l'occurrence c'est c'est
c'est vraiment marqué le coup parce
qu'on on ne peut pas accepter
qu'effectivement les déficits se
creusent d'année en année vous êtes
d'accord vous êtes d'accord et il faut
qu' il faut il faut qu'on cherche il
faut qu'on cherche ensemble alors du
coup à à réduire ce déficit moi je vous
ai parlé de la performance des dépenses
il faut qu'on travail sur justement la
qualité l'efficience des dépenses on a
beaucoup parlé des des recettes pendant
ces c'est ces derniers ces dernières
heures on a beaucoup parlé de de
recettes supplémentaires ou de de de
dépenses en moins et et d'exonération en
plus c'est vrai qu'on a dépensé un petit
peu d'argent je je je le regrette vous
l'avez dit et je crois que vous allez
nous nous nous annoncer le coût des des
exonérations supplémentaires en tout cas
monsieur le ministre messieurs les
ministres voilà nous arrivons à l'issue
de cette partie du PLFSS et et vous
redire que pour nous il n'est aucunement
question de laisser la dette aux
générations futures surtout la dette de
de nos consultations parce qu'il s'agit
bien surtout du déficit de l'assurance
maladie merci chers
collègu
l'amendement 523 tombe il est pas
défendu dans l'hémicycle je passe au
735 madame swiiris merci monsieur le
Président cet amendement effectivement
vise à supprimer l'article 16
oui nous avons besoin d'une vision à
long termme du financement de la
sécurité sociale et d'une programmation
pluriannuelle en matière de santé
sociale c'était d'ailleurs l'objet de
l'un de mes amendements jugé irrecevable
ce qui devait être acté dans une loi
organique en tout cas c'est une
proposition que je vous soumé mais non
cette prévision n'est pas soutenable ou
réaliste le gouvernement considère ainsi
une une prévision de croissance de 1,4 %
supérieure à celle du consensus des
économistes plus 0,8 %. et il prévoit un
déficit croissant de la sécurité sociale
sur des hypothèses d'inflation
optimistes c'est dire je ne mpenche pas
davantage sur ces éléments financiers
contenus dans l'avis du Haut Conseil des
finances publiques de plus cette
prévision n'entame aucun virage
écologique ou d'investissement massif
pour notre santé pour toutes ces raisons
nous proposons de supprimer l'article 16
merci merci chers collègues nous passons
à l'amendement 916 madame Brulin merci
monsieur le Président nous proposons
aussi la suppression de cet article 16
qui prévoit l'évolution pluriannuelle du
financement de la sécurité sociale pour
les années 23 à 27 le gouvernement s'est
engagé envers Bruxelles à limiter la
hausse des dépenses publiques à 0,6 %
par an pour contenir les déficits en
dessous des 3 %. les dépenses de
l'assurance maladie qui progressent
seulement de 3,2 % cette année sont
plafonné à 3 % en 2025 et à 2,9 en
2026 cette trajectoire pluriannuelle des
régimes obligatoires de base est en
total décalage avec la crise des
hôpitaux les difficultés des acteurs de
santé les besoins pour l'accompagnement
de nos aînés pour améliorer la prise en
charge des familles et des personnes en
situation de handicap de plus la branche
vieillesse voit son excédent se creuser
à 14 milliards d'euros en 2027 qui
suffit à montrer toute l'inefficacité de
la réforme des retraites imposée au pays
pour mémoire le Conseil d'orientation
des retraites estimé avant la réforme le
déficit de 2027 se situerait entre 7,5
et 10 milliards d'euros vous avez donc
ajouté de années de travail et une année
de cotisation à l'ensemble des salariés
au nom de l'équilibre du système des
retraites pour finalement doubler le
déficit prévu en 2027 ces choix sont
absolument contre prodoductif nous ne
sommes pas les seuls à le penser dans ce
pays je pense notamment aux
organisations syndicales et je
terminerai en disant comme d'autres
collègues l'ont dit nous voilà 2 jours
et demi que nous vous proposons des
recettes nouvelles nous pourrions avoir
un débat sur l'orientation de ces
retrait ces recettes le
l'ampleur des cotisations à prélever ou
pas et ce débat est interdit au motif
que la seule
euh piste à suivre est celle de la
réduction des dépenses on voit bien que
ça n'est plus possible que notre système
ne peut plus aller plus loin dans la
réduction des dépenses et nous
regrettons que ce débat ne puisse pas
avoir lieu nous vous remerci mer chers
collègues l'amendement 1285 madame
leerou non allez-y allez-y monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Ministre chers
collègues alors nous partageons
évidemment tout ce qu'on pu dire nos
collègues du groupe écologiste et du
groupe communiste nous dénonçons une
nouvelle fois la logique de restriction
restriction évidemment sanitaire
restriction médico-sociale qui est de
toute façon une logique perdante à moyen
et long terme et sur le plan médical
pour pour nos concitoyens et sur le plan
budgétaire pour les finances publiques
nous appelons nous aussi avec cet
amendement à la suppression de l'article
16 Rappelz ici que le groupe socialiste
écologiste et républicain lors du
précédent PLFSS avait contesté le
transfert de la dette covid 17,7
milliards d'euros à la cadè une mesure
qui a durablement fragiliser les comptes
de la Sécurité sociale nous avions à
l'époque dit et nous le pensons toujours
euh que cette dette aurait dû être
supportée par l'État parce qu'un certain
nombre d'éléments de cette dette très
clairement ne relevait pas d'émissions
ordinaires de la branche maladie
eu sur les projections du gouvernement
on a déjà eu l'occasion de le répéter à
plusieurs reprises la dégradation va
aller là aussi en s'accélérant au cours
des prochaines années 11,2 milliards de
déficit en 2024 17,1 milliards en 2026 à
contrario
si cette dette n'était pas
intégrée les administrations de sécurité
sociale dégageraiit un fort excédent 0,5
points de PIB en 2022 0,8 points en 2023
autant de moyens supplémentaires qui
pourraient être remis au bénéfice de
l'hôpital public au bénéfice de nos
éepad au bénéfice de nos soyants au
bénéfice de nos concitoyens c'est la
raison pour laquelle nous appelons à
voter cet amendement de suppression
merci Merci Quel l'avis du Gouvernement
sur ces amendements de suppression de
l'article 16 monsieur ministre cet
article monsieur le Président cet
article 16 me semble bien mal engagé à à
vous
écouter et je voudrais avant de donner
mon avis et puis de de passer le relais
au ministre de la santé et de la
prévention c'est bien dommage de
terminer cette cette P2 sur sur cet
échec de ma part de de conviction mais
surtout je voudrais réagir à au propos
de la rapporteur générale au nom de la
commission des affaires sociales vous
parlez d'or bien sûr que nous sommes
préoccupés par la situation financière
de la sécurité sociale que nous avons
des économies à faire mais j'aurais eu
beaucoup de mal à vous convaincre
pendant ces 25 heur beaucoup beaucoup de
mal à vous convaincre parce qu'à l'issue
de ces 25 heur entre nous nous avons
dégradé un peu plus la situation de la
sécurité sociale plus d'1,2 milliards
1,2 milliards et ce n'est pas faute de
l'avoir dit quand j'ai vu arriver les
amendements successifs par fois parfois
à coup de 20 50 millions en disant C son
de miter le rendement de nos cotisations
sociales donc effectivement je partage
votre préoccupation la nécessité de
redresser les finances sociales je
constate que c'est difficile la preuve
on ressort hélas avec une situation plus
dégradée que qu'à l'entrée et je ne
parle pas de de l'État avec 2,5
milliards d'euros de son côté de
financement
amputé néanmoins néanmoins je voulais
vous redire le le plaisir que j'ai eu
aussi à débattre avec chacune et et
chacun d'entre vous même si
effectivement ce n'est pas tout à fait
la conclusion que j'aurais aimé partager
avec vous sur cet article 16 néanmoins
il me revient de vous dire que cet
article il est important euh et donc
j'aiimis un avis défavorable à tous ces
amendements sans surprise merci la
parole est à Madame Apopi pour
explication de vote oui euh monsieur le
ministre oui 25h pour ce voilà enfin les
débats sur la partie recette de la
sécurité sociale pour 2024 ont permis je
pense quand même d'affronter des projets
de société qui ne sont pas les mêmes
nous n'avons pas le même projet de
société euh et puis avec nos amendements
nous vous avons proposé des choses
monsieur le ministre alors avant que
vous ne partiez parce que vous allez
partir vous allez nous quitter ah non
mais là là je ne vous souhaite pas ça
monsieur le minist j'en suis pas là
quand même euh alors vous j'en suis pas
là excusez-moi
je même si ce soir je vous en veux un
peu quand même enfin en tous les cas je
n'en suis pas là alors vous dites qu'on
a dégradé les comptes un peu plus de la
sécurité sociale ah ben moi je vais vous
proposer là dans quelques minutes de
remettre à flot le budget de la Sécurité
sociale puis pour que vous dormiez bien
bah je vais vous rappeler les quelques
amendements que nous vous avons fait et
que je pense vous avez refusé par
dogmatisme par parce que le dogmatisme
pas n'est pas chez nous mais il est chez
vous alors je vous je vais quand même
vous en rappeler quelques-uns nous vous
avons proposé d'augmenter les sanctions
contre la fraude aux cotisations
patronal d'augmenter le taux de la
contribution sociale généralisée sur les
produits de patrimoinees et les produits
de placement de renforcer la taxation
des retraites chapeau des dirigeants des
grandes entreprises d'augmenter le taux
de cotisation des stocks option et des
actions gratuites d'augmenter le taux de
forfait social sur les plans d'éparne
retraite l'intéressement et la
participation d'augmenter la
contribution des employeurs d'instituer
une contribution de solidarité des
actionnaires d'instituer une
contribution sociale exceptionnelle des
sociétés réalisées réalisant des super
profits d'instituer une contribution des
revenus financiers d'instituer une
contribution sur les revenus des épat
privé lucratif de supprimer les
exonérations de cotisation sociale et
enfin de les conditionner à des craires
sociaux bonne nuit monsieur le ministre
merci merci chers collègues je veux
mettre au voie ces amendements de
suppression de l'article 16 avec un avis
favorable de la commission et un avis
défavorable du gouvernement qui est
[Musique]
pour qui est
contre qui
s'abstient ces amendements sont adoptés
et font tomber l'article 16 dans sa
totalité nous passons ensuite à des
articles additionnel après l'article 16
et nous commençons par deux amendements
identiques il s'agit du 110 défendu par
Monsieur
Milon